20 21 shaping up to be the year of  rescheduled weddings popular wedding  site the knot reports couples ordering  save the date announcements  more than tripled at the start of this  year compared to back in the fall of  2020  and even as ceremonies get back on track  guests still want to know about wedding  safety precautions  follow your cdc guidelines follow your  local and state guidelines and think  about things you can do to make your  guests feel more comfortable  put that information on your wedding  website let them know if you're wearing  masks if you're mandating vaccines  that will make everyone feel a little  safer when they're celebrating jessica  and with so many rescheduled ceremonies  right now there's a lot of competition  for venues and services  wedding planners say couples have to be  creative and flexible  before walking down the aisle